what a pretty monumental in Lenin's
Isaac's is behind a broad Kazakh okay
not going to get locked up looks matter
at all painted it diamond for the play
on the topside Keane pops withdrew I
can't do the damage whoa okay idiom
securing first what for froggen are they
gonna keep chasing subject once it oh he
is 25 after the saw stop cuz I get
meself the kill definitely a huge fan of
the champion so much damage in him the
KD and a great performances too so I
mean the young junglers in the league
right now are looking really really good
[Music]
filing so I think if cating can contain
mood cause because of the champion you
really need to keep down you probably
got beat in 1v1 but if you know how he
is
that doesn't lessen the impact on your
lanes and I kadian be showing so much
presence for his team early already what
before right now is good trying to get
the assassination down but ball taking
too much damage occur [ __ ] stand the
grounds are ya going to revive
elimination of almost one upon as loop
ups trying to keep alive moods going to
take him down the highs open it
doing a nice chunk of a leaves echovox
need to get back to their beats they're
gonna get cut off here we plume the bay
I probably gonna try and turn around
that's a flush out there supporting any
luck no matter how awkward
no matter wrapping we roll around flag
was brought it steady - an egg once
again this is all s a trooper woman
coming out as well as block let's run it
through the fight now the hole is going
to be communicating the side of the road
back let's do that one
sit down in Blackfoot gonna try turn
around that's a second because exes
Brogan's we're just finding out where he
kept and he plucked out again made a
ripple kill for food that's like let's
just going up that's like water there as
well loop up he's run away but we could
smell the Penta moon with the flank
there and that could be the game I think
it will then moon has so much patience
he waits until someone is low gets it
excuse take down the ad carry then goes
for froggen as students kha'zix is going
nuts like this there's no chance in the
fight right you have to have a concerted
effort to locking down and killing that
Kazakh when he goes in and as soon as he
was able to get that free rein in the
backline the fight was done so the moon
deserves a lot of credit and also a team
high class real clean and gamers we've
always see them they're gonna pull up
another deciding game yeah where was the
advantage in the draft for fly quest it
was the Cossacks right that was really
what it was Akkadian was pushed down on
the graves he sought us all his game but
move was 9 0 and 8 you wouldn't know
here comes Moon through the vision
controls of the mid lane that fog of war
you couldn't even see moon coming in the
spike come out and first blood some moon
chalks up another one balls deep in
attacking here comes moon the call field
damage coming through right like just
missing the burning lot explaining
safeguard to a minion but no more shield
for that one and you go down another one
for moon 2 and all at the Starks Paris
is just going to get started up my
Carlotta gaming
alright we'll scratch our heads later on
that one Enoch Rustin goes out he's just
trying to lock him down six days all
apparent oh he's got to use the
Quicksilver guitar that was I boots
going to give him a kiss and fly back
out he says hello
what a play here to start off I didn't
you'll never sit on which is like a
really good improvement for me and I
think it's just my team has my back and
my team has confidence in me which helps
more than anything else yeah we talked
about some of the rookies and akkadian
showed up bigger than any of them only
jungler in the NA LCS after week one to
have 100% first blood participation he
got that in all five games four of them
he actually got the kill the problem
with the Canadian is he wasn't
necessarily able to transition that into
wins Emma can you see a flame I think he
knows that something's up it's got a
glass
can it get himself out of the way okay
can he make up over my leg then again he
got him as he flashed to he predicted
the fog he put himself in the leaf to
get ahead the akkadian of covering for
the rest of his team he's just everyone
respond to one thing he wants a life
something up seven is Erik 18 again two
zeros again Akkadian off to a great
start here indicating at least that was
another free one I'd be mortal football
for two of those games the losses this
man just has something going on it comes
to killing people for the first time to
cope out there he has the ultimate buddy
oh right into there oh no feels bad gets
exhausted again is going to chase him
that can be another kill boiling before
a flat photo
6000 kildeer anything like that but
right now that's a dead cotija another
pick and I can't even get credit but I
still won four five kills now is a carry
jungler right now
and he has been doing wonders for this
squad because normally be like alright
another echo fox game where we do
nothing for the first part but now
they're very very actively V's maybe
we're the call button ah you are kidding
me
blood blood that compared the Acadian
and even though it's until the very end
but of course you got it again yeah
eight of nine man's the new first flood
King I'm telling you we got to take it
away from yank oh these guys are playing
aggressive they are taking risks they
are pushing their advantages and this is
not the echo fox though we have seen in
the past it's a new team and they are
cracking the bass at 26 minutes in those
clubs on looking clean and step one jet
it has to be control subject he's out of
control in an explicitly assassinations
auto feed on contract gonna get it
turned around plus the old Dean gets
away wash away its get a good old
contract to tax it and I'm just gonna
turn around as a bit of help from these
rumbling in fact looks like it as well
and get the gone fit on a what a
turnaround from cloud nine oh no that's
the old seated contract for NASA
my Oh so greedy for the way lots of
damage when else not not gonna come as a
contract with eight one and nine which
is seventeen of 20 kills participated in
just that one death so still a very
solid performance by cloud nine contract
a rookie player looks very clean and
when we know he's talented but you can
very easily integrate it into that team
the party but still feels and I able to
pull the turn LC is going to die with
one hostile roles of some movie replayed
by two Orianna the recenter they're
double kill so far in four contracts how
many more can they get re re re
I don't rate so they won't take my
damage you would expect them to this is
going to be a pretty solid very pick of
contract over the wall not even a
problem plan II can detach about
shockwave a smoothie but if it take
you've ever gone
he's gone Jensen finding more crews out
of the mixin to kill them up if they can
stick they've got to break this out but
Contras is too much damage and it's a
for v3 advantage cloud 9 15 X up on the
table and that's all she wrote for b2
found out of the woman's mouth and
clouds I have done it 4 and 0 2 and week
two undefeated undisputed first place in
North America
[Applause]
you